thank you so much Candace and we made it
now that the 15's back open between
Flamingo and Russell thought you might
appreciate seeing and hearing exactly
why it was closed
[Music]
endot project manager Lynette Russell
explained it very simply for us Friday
morning sometimes you can have freeway
traffic down below but in this case
we're taking down the the overpass a
portion of it and that will mean we'll
have falling pieces of concrete and
rebar and this is really a safety
measure well we do necessary
infrastructure improvements one of those
improvements may take some getting used
to yeah Tropicana is back open but only
two lanes each for East and Westbound
travel and in what may seem like an odd
possibly dangerous setup that's known as
a diverging diamond interchange where
traffic appears to be moving in the
wrong direction and if it sounds like
we're repeating ourselves we are because
you need to understand this now drivers
in the Henderson who live off the 95 515
there at Horizon Drive they've had a
diverging diamond for a few years now so
if and when you venture onto the new
setup at trop please take it easy until
you and all the other drivers get used
to it a pro tip for MnDOT once the
entire project is done in 2025 Trump
will be back to four so-called normal
Lanes in each Direction there will not
be a diverging diamond there is one now
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone and join the driving a
crazy conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com